Nice!
Woah!
Wood Face!
Hoffentlich pendelt sich das jetzt ein klei.
Naja, jetzt gehts anscheinend.
Wo davon ist so ein Kackladen, Alter?
Ah, das gibt's nicht!
Ich hoffe das backt jetzt nicht wieder übelst rum.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall irgendwann noch mal ein Kack-Woder von Emote.
Oh, ihr seid ja schon am Start hier, der Michael 50 Billion ist am Start, der Patrick
ist am Start, Moonbeard Desmond am Start, der U-Mode auch wieder, Credo ist da, Conti
Attacks, Galaga, Somniac Dude, Remember Wookiee, jetzt kommen alle, alle kommen an den Start.
Sieht gut aus, also anscheinend spackt es jetzt nicht rum, es hat bloß initial einfach
mal gar nichts funktioniert, ein paar Woder von Gravidda, schauen wir mal, fastest du?
Okay, warum sollte ich fasten?
Ostern ist ja schon lang vorbei, also das ist ja das wo die meisten, ach ist es Ramadan
oder sowas?
Naja, ich hab's mit keiner Glaubensrichtung, also wer da an Sachen glauben will, kann das
ruhig machen, aber ich nicht.
Fast, ich hab grad 6 Stücke Toastbrot gefressen, weil ich den ganzen Tag sonst nichts gefordert
hab.
Und dann auch noch wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig gesunde Toastbrotmischung, nämlich 3 Stück
Nutella, 3 Stück Erdnussbutter.
Du frierst eine vor allem ein, bist du voll, warum soll ich die nicht einfrieren?
Wäre doch bescheuert, eh mal neu zu starten, oder?
Uiuiui, da ist aber ganz schön viele, ganz schön viele Sachen übrig, Anfragen, muss
man sich das gleich mal kurz angucken.
Glaubst du an die Progasgürteln?
Gürteln?
Ich muss mal den Chat neu laden, irgendwie hängt's bei mir, was soll das dann sein?
So, jetzt, es funktioniert.
Moin, Captain Seekai, soll mal schnell hier im Schnelldurchgang mal die ganzen Questions
abhaken.
Ahjaja, Moment, warum spakt das rum?
Äh, ist meine Abfrage fail im Frontend, dass ich gar nicht alle Sachen abfrage, sondern
nur 100 oder so?
Würdest du, wenn du die Wahl hättest, oh das ist eine interessante Frage, würdest du
wenn du die Wahl hättest, Schule, mal Ausbildung in Informatik machen?
Hm, gut, der Coding Niklas ist wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht da, weil ich nicht weiß von wann
die Frage ist, wahrscheinlich vom vorletzten Stream oder sowas, das kann man so pauschal
finde ich gar nicht, gar nicht sagen.
Es kommt drauf an, wo dein Schwerpunkt ist, also wenn du die ganzen theoretischen Kramen
wissen willst, oder vielleicht auch später, ja was gibt's da eigentlich theoretisches
Data Science, keine Ahnung, machen willst, dann ja, aber man muss sagen, die meisten
Leute die Informatik studiert haben, landen dann irgendwann auch ganz normal in irgendeinem
Programmiert Job oder sonst wo, ein paar machen wahrscheinlich irgendwelche akademischen
Sachen, aber die meisten eher nicht, im Durchschnitt wirst du, wenn du studiert hast, trotzdem
ein bisschen mehr verdienen, das wars jetzt aber über die Stelle, die du dann speziell
das auch nicht viel aussagst, Compilerbau, exellent, Compilerbau, ja ich glaub die wenigsten
Leute sitzen wirklich am Compilerbau, Moment warum ist die Frage jetzt weg, hab ich die
raus für den gelöscht, oder, ok ich glaub wir müssen, wo fangen wir jetzt am besten
an, mein, mein, mein Fragen Board ist kaputt, das zeigt Fragen in komischer Reihenfolge
dann, was hältst du eigentlich vor Lutris, also vor dem Linux Gaming Launcher, ja das
ist nicht schlecht, leider gibt's halt unter Linux so wenig Spiele, also die wirklich ordentlich
supporten, die man ohne Beine ausreißen ordentlich zu laufen kriegt, es wird immer besser, aber
solang es da keinen offiziellen Support gibt wird das nie gut werden, zumal man alle Spiele
mit Anti-Cheat eh vergessen kann, das ist das Problem, es gibt auf YouTube so viele Videos,
Linux die bessere Gaming Alternative, was eigentlich, was denn, natürlich ist im Vergleich
zu Windows, Linux auf keinen Fall die bessere Gaming Alternative, kommt heute nix, ich weiß
ja nicht was wir heute machen, keine Ahnung, ich muss erstmal fragen, wahrscheinlich nicht,
aber ich kann euch mal erzählen was ich mir aufgeschrieben hab, was man alles machen kann,
ne kann ich nicht, weil ich hab meine Notes nicht gesyncht vorher, aber ein paar Sachen,
ich hab nämlich was cooles gefunden, das gucken wir uns demnächst an, so, was macht
man denn, was macht denn ein ITler vor Ort, Windows Pass, ok da weiß ich jetzt nicht
mal was ich das bezogen hat, nein war ich noch nie, ich war schon ein paar Mal eingeladen,
hab aber noch nie in die USA gefahren, keine Ahnung wie es da ist, ah da haben wir anscheinend
Barbecue Pit Boys geguckt, oh das ist ja ewig her, das Stream, das kann ich jetzt alles mal
löschen, so, ähm, hast du morgen eigentlich arbeiten, ich wusste wahrscheinlich, ja, ja
was, das ist auch sowas, du solltest mal ein Video machen, in dem du den Leuten erklärst,
dass es wichtiger ist zu googeln und zu suchen zu lernen, als alles andere beim Programmieren,
ja das ist so, weiß nicht ob ich da ein Video drüber machen sollte, ähm, das ist in fast
jedem Beruf wo es um Technik geht heutzutage fast das wichtigste, dass man ordentlich suchen
kann und ich sehs bei uns ja, ähm, wenn ich mir da die Leute anguck, die jetzt gerade
Homeoffice machen, vor allem die die schon ein bisschen älter sind, das ist jetzt kein
Flame, gegen ein bisschen ältere, weil es gibt auch genug die das hinkriegen, aber gerade
die, die halt so, äh, aus Zeiten von Handbüchern, Handbücher lesen und, und, äh, Kobold und
Lochkarten, ne, also, die können ruhig schon ein bisschen jünger sein, ähm, aber Leute,
es gibt, es gibt ja welche, die, ähm, die finden das als Niederlage wenn sie googeln
müssen, so nach dem Motto, oh fuck, ich weiß es nicht, krieg es nicht alleine raus, ich
muss googeln, aber es ist viel einfacher, gerade in der heutigen Zeit wo es Seiten wie
Stackoverflow gibt, ist das viel effektiver was zu googeln anstatt seine 3 Stunden selbstraum
zu probieren.
Ich, mich würde mal interessieren, dass, ey, ich hab ne richtig geile Idee für ein Video
bzw. für ein Stream, aber ich weiß nicht wie wir das machen, und zwar, ähm, oh, Danny,
Void Danny Twitch Prime 8 Monate, huge, das ist ja schon, das ist weder, noch Prime Subscriber,
dass es 8 Monat ist, Max, du bist dick, oh fuck, kokona style, ähm, ja, ich hatte richtig
gute Idee für den Stream, was ich gerade gesagt hab, es gibt so viel, was man auf Stackoverflow
und so kopieren kann, man müsste mal nen Stream machen, wo man sich das Ziel setzt, ne,
irgendeine billige, was kleines, ja, ähm, irgendeine kleine Anwendung zu basteln, und
das nur mit Copy Paste von Stackoverflow, Clocks HD, 8 Monat, ajajaja, Q-Chat, man müsste
jetzt echt mal probieren, irgendwas kleines, ähm, hast du dir schon mal meine, ich hab
mir die meisten, ne, ich hab's noch nicht angeschaut, die meisten Sachen, ähm, das
muss irgendwas kleines sein, irgendwas in Richtung, was könnte man, was, was, was würden
sie sich da anbieten, äh, irgendeine Konsolenanwendung oder so, irgendwas, wo man schön copy pasten
kann, ne, eine, das für ne reine, reine Copy, vielleicht, sag mal, sag mal ne 95% reine
Copy Paste Anwendung geht schlecht, aber ne 95% Copy Paste Anwendung machen und gucken,
was dann am Ende rauskommt, oh Leute, der Scam Train ist am Start, war da, 2 Monate
abonniert, huge Subscriber, du hast nur wenig Zeit, 94% Leute, jetzt wird's aber knapp,
der Scam Train läuft, ja, äh, A-Max hat der Kix eigentlich immer noch eine Muschi, jetzt
jeder kommt aufs Auge des Betrachters an, oh, war da vorn, was los, ach ne, das geht,
geht nur runter, ähm, so, was haben wir sonst noch für schöne Fragen gehabt, aber ja,
das, das, also ja, ja, das soll ich vielleicht mal wirklich machen, machst du im Moment andere
Tätigkeit in deinem Job wegen der Quarantäne, ne, ich mach eigentlich genau das gleiche,
vor allem ist es sogar eher mehr, weil, weil man im Homeoffice total vielen Leuten hinterher
rennen muss, ich, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt, ob es ein paar Leute, ich hab ja gestern
ein bisschen rumgerantet, ähm, auf Twitter, über manche Leute im Homeoffice, ähm, und
zwar finde ich, der Vergleich triffts, triffts eigentlich gut, ähm, gestern Abend gab es
nämlich mal wieder so ne, so ne Mail, wo sich unser Management gefreut hat, wie gut und
toll das Homeoffice funktioniert, wo ich mich dann so gefragt hab, ok, ähm, mit, mit was
die teilweise schon zufrieden sind, ist lustig, aber, das sind halt alles auch irgendwelche
Boomer-Manager, die sich das wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht vorstellen konnten, dass
die Leute, wenn man sie in Ruhe lässt, auch was arbeiten. Es gibt eh im Homeoffice total
viele Leute, gerade im, gerade im BWL und Management-Bereich, die, die jetzt, die jetzt
echt, denen geht der Arsch auf Grundeis, und wisst ihr warum? Weil durch diese ganze Homeoffice-Geschichte
haben die große Probleme ihre Existenz zu rechtfertigen, ja, weil was machst du als
irgendwelchen, kennst du den Tim von Alpha 4 Games, nicht, also nicht so richtig von
Angesicht zu Angesicht, ne, kennen ist auch zu viel gesagt, wir hatten nur, glaub mal,
eine kurze Begegnung im Voice-Chat, vor einiger Zeit, ist ganz lang her. Ja, aber ich hab
den Eindruck, viele Leute haben echt Probleme, äh, so ihre Existenz zu rechtfertigen, gerade,
gerade halt, äh, bei dieser ganzen Homeoffice-Thematik, weil wozu brauchst du jetzt einen, ähm, was
gibt's denn da, was gibt's denn da für, für, für schöne Sachen, einen Prozess-Requirements-blah,
sonst war's Typ, ja, ist grad komplett useless, und die wissen grad nicht so genau, was sie
machen sollen, hast du nicht mal so ein Stampf-Game für alte F4-Games gemacht, doch, doch, das
war das ja, wo wir mal kurz zusammen im Voice-Chat waren, das war die einzige Begegnung, die
ich mal mit ihm hatte. Ähm, Pater, was, Moment, wie heißt der Name? Pater Oherli, jetzt kann
ich die aussprechen, schreibt, äh, unsere Angestellten denken, dass der Chef wieder
Schichtdienst einführt mit Ausreden Loadbalancing der VPN-Server. Was zum Teufel hat Schichtdienst
mit dem Loadbalancing der VPN-Server zu tun? Der Zusammenhang klingt mir grad voll random.
Oh, der Keeper XY ist da, der weiß sogar von welchen Leuten ich rede vielleicht. Ja, aber
was ich witzig finde, ähm, ich hab's ja, ich hab's hier auf Twitter geschrieben, also
erstens bei uns überschlägt sich halt das Management voll, wie gut das Ganze läuft.
Kommt überhaupt nicht mit dem Chat hinterher, Leute. Ähm, klar weißt du, wen ich mein,
das glaub ich nicht, ich mein gar keinen wirklich jetzt so bestimmten, wenn ich das
sag. Ähm, wir haben ja ein paar, die im Homeoffice echt so ein bisschen ihre Probleme haben.
Zumindest ich find den Vergleich mit dem MMO eigentlich ganz gut, ja. Es gibt auch im Homeoffice
viele Leute, die sind einfach nicht in der Lage ihre Klasse richtig zu spielen, ja. Das
ist dann sowas wie Melee Heiler oder, oder, oder, äh, Damage, äh, oder, keine Ahnung,
Caster der heilen will oder Damage, ähm, Buffer oder irgendwie sowas, ja. Da hast du
dann halt Leute daheim sitzen, wo du denkst, ok, der müsste das eigentlich können. Und
dann stellst du dir einmal fest, der kann das nicht. So, jetzt wusste ich, ich komm
im Chat ja gerade wirklich überhaupt nicht nach, was ist denn hier los. Ähm, was denkst
du eigentlich dazu, dass es immer weniger Leute auf YouTube gibt, die Commentaries machen?
Also, ja gut, das zieht halt nicht mehr. Na, du kannst ja Reaction Content machen. Also
man kann ja Reaction Content, da stehen ja die Leute zur Zeit total drauf. Reaction Content
muss sein. Oh, huge, huge Song hier. Das ist, das ist, ähm, A Link to the Past, das ist
nicht Dark World, ist das nicht das Schloss? Doch, das ist das Schloss, das Schloss, Castle,
Castle Theme, oder? Moment, gucke. Ok, ja, es ist, es ist A Link Between Worlds, aber
es ist der gleiche, exakt gleiche, gleiche Soundtrack, oder fast gleiche Soundtrack, bloß
ein bisschen neuer gemacht. Äh, oh, ho, sagt. Ähm, hab mal eine Frage, du benutzt ja auch
Windows 10? Äh, ja, mal kurz. Jetzt kann man was, jetzt machen. So. Ah, muss ja immer
dafür sorgen, dass die Leute aufmerksam bleiben, oder ist, ist beste, wenn was auf den Bildschirm
passiert. So, jetzt passiert was auf dem Bildschirm, weil wir wissen ja alle, die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne
der Zuschauer ist ja heutzutage ist nicht hoch. Da muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen was machen.
Oh, perfekt. Äh, hab mal ne Frage, du benutzt ja auch Windows 10 und hast da ne VM auf dem
zweiten Desktop. Mit Ctrl, Windows plus rechts plus links kann man ja zwischen Windows 10
und VM wechseln. Ja, du kannst, du kannst, äh, zwischen, zwischen virtuellen Desktop
wechseln, also du musst nicht unbedingt ne VM sein. Ja, wenn ich in der VM bin, muss
ich, um da rauszukommen, erstmal Ctrl alt drücken und kann erst wieder rüber zu Windows
10 switchen. Da sind sie, ja, das stimmt. Hast du da ne Lösung, wie man das mit weniger
Tasten geht? Das kann ich dir erzählen, ähm, weil das Problem hatte ich auch. Äh, hab
versucht mit AutoHotkey das zu automatisieren, aber da gibts dann Probleme mit VM-Ware und
deren Keyboard-Rapier. AutoHotkey funktioniert nicht, bringt vollkommen Milchbrot. Dankeschön
für die zwei Monate, huge Subscriber. Excellent, hrq-sub. Ayayar. Ähm, also mit AutoHotkey
geht nicht. V.a. wer hat irgendeinen Low-Level-USB, äh, frag mich nicht, Keyboard-Driver, da
ist mit AutoHotkey nix. Äh, was du machen kannst ist, wenn du ne Maus beziehungsweise
ne Tastatur hast, die halt ne, ne Macrosoftware dabei hat, Cozart, Logitech, was auch immer,
da kannst du das programmieren. Das funktioniert, das hab ich auch gemacht. Allerdings hab ich
das hier nicht drinnen, sondern hier drück ich immer, äh, Ctrl alt, Ctrl alt und dann
Ctrl Windows links. Ist ein bisschen Übungssache, aber ich hab mir das in der Logitech-Software
gebuffelt, dass genau das Ganze funktioniert. Damit geht das. Ähm, gibt es eigentlich
die Knu... Knu... Eus noch? Was? Was für ein Ding? Knu-E-U-W-S? Was ist das? Oh, der
Scamtrain-Level 2. 3 Sekunden, Leute. 3 Sekunden. Er ist da vorbei. Der Scamtrain ist abgefahren.
Ähm... Also, Pater, ich muss sagen, das ist ne sehr merkwürdige Geschichte, weil eure
VPN-Software ausgelastet sind. Ach, jetzt hab ich, jetzt versteh ich das. Euer Chef
will Schichtarbeit einführen, weil die VPN-Software ausgelastet sind, mit dem ihr euch auf die
Arbeit einloggt. Ach so. Kann man da nicht einfach noch ein paar VPN-Software dazustellen?
Vor allem, was habt... Mein, VPN, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade OpenVPN ist, merkwürdig
konfiguriert, hält es sich doch in Grenzen. Einfach noch, einfach noch was dazu, einfach
mit Hardware erschlagen, das geht doch bestimmt. Wenn natürlich eure Anbindung zu langsam
ist, ja, aber trotzdem. Bescheuerte Idee. Max, du willst Content auf YouTube einfach
Reactions auf Quellcode? Exzellent. Reactions-Videos zu Reaction-Videos. Ja, das hab ich letztens
auch gesehen. Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, war so, war, war, war komplett weird. Das
war so nach dem Motto, Unge reagiert auf Inscope21, der auf MontanaBlack reagiert. Ja, ich weiß
euch jetzt vorbei, das ist echt abgefahren. Spielst du immer noch Path of Exile oder auch
noch was anderes? Ich spiel gerade noch nicht mal mehr Path of Exile, ich spiel grad, äh,
gar nichts. Ich, ich spiel grad den Doom Singleplayer noch mal auf schwer, ein bisschen schwerer.
Aber ansonsten, also der hat der Dings hier Doom Eternal, aber ansonsten, äh, gerade
wenig, ja. Äh, da hast du recht. John hat eine DVD, hast du einen Streamplan. Ich hab
mir das tatsächlich überlegt, ob wir nicht einen Streamplan machen, aber ihr kennt mich.
Wenn ich sag, wir machen einen Streamplan, dann setzt mich das immer irgendwie unter
Zugzwang und ich machs nicht. Deswegen werd ich wahrscheinlich keinen Streamplan machen.
Der Kommentar, das hat dir, das hat dir gefallen, ne? Übrigens, der Kommentator, der hat nicht
Ubi gesagt, der hat Rubi gesagt. Das ist eine Programmiersprache. Äh, KeeperFX, bist du
noch da? Kennst du noch den Typ bei uns, der, ähm, der vor seinem Rechner gesessen hat
und den PC Speaker anhatte, wenn er mit der Maustaste, mit der Maustaste an den Rand gekommen
ist und dann gesagt hat, der scheiß Gnome und ab und zu, und ab und zu gesagt hat, Rubi,
der vom Rechner gesessen hat. Den hatten wir damals für ZFS, für Mail ZFS geholt und
haben uns dann überlegt, wir wollen doch kein ZFS, wo er da war. Wie gut kennst du dich
mit Shadern aus? Das einzige, was ich bei Shadern weiß, ist der Unterschied zwischen
einem Pixel-Shader und einem Vertax-Shader, dass der eine sagt, welche Farbe der Pixel
hat und der andere sagt, wo der Pixel ist. Ansonsten hab ich keine Ahnung. Also Michael
50 Billionen, ich glaube, ich hab die letzten Sonntage, äh, innerhalb, ich glaube, ich
hab das letzte Jahr über, ähm, einmal sonntags nicht gestreamt. Der mir, ja mir fällt
grad auch was ein, wo ich erzähle, der Typ, der bei uns auf der Arbeit da gesessen hat
und, und PC Speaker anhatte. Wir hatten auch mal einen, der war auch geil, der hat immer
auf seine Tastatur geschlagen, wenn was nicht funktioniert hat. Und das ging einem mega
auf den Sack. Das ist dann, irgendwas, irgendwas hat nicht funktioniert, was er gebastelt hat
und dann saß er dann echt da. Das war eh einer, der hat ganz harte Aufmerksamkeit,
also ganz irgendwie Aufmerksamkeitsprobleme gehabt, weil, ähm, also, dass er die bekommt,
denn, ähm, der hat meiner Meinung nach auch eigenhändlich dafür gesorgt, dass eine
Auszubildende nicht mehr zu uns in die Gruppe wollte, ne. Also, und, und er hat Liegestütze
im Büro gemacht, sowas, der war echt ein bisschen neben der Spur. Der ist manchmal
aufgesprungen, hat angefangen, Liegestützen zu machen. Leck, oh, Leck, wo davon? Der ist
manchmal aufgesprungen, hat angefangen, Liegestützen zu machen. Mitten, mitten im Büro, wo alle
da gesessen haben und haben gearbeitet und irgendwann haben's alle ignoriert und haben
quasi absichtlich weggeguckt, wenn er angefangen hat. Ja, zumindest, wir hatten mal eine Auszubildende
einer der wenigen Mädels, äh, IT-technisch, ja, und die ist dann bei uns ins Büro gekommen,
hat irgendwas gefragt und da hat er seine Charme-Offensive gestartet und, ähm, hat sich
dann quasi in den Türrahmen gestellt und hat so Stretch-Übungen gemacht, so, um quasi
so ein bisschen männliche, äh, Dominanz, äh, auszustrahlen und das hat die echt komplett,
äh, auf den falschen Fuß erwischt und die wollte nie wieder bei uns in die Gruppe irgendwie
dann was, was da machen. Ist auch, ist auch ein Depp, warum macht er auch so Zeug, ja?
Aber wir müssen jetzt leider warten, bis Wodafone sich wieder, bis Wodafone ausgeschissen
hat. Seit wann kann man Kekse sammeln, äh, seit zwei Streams? Ach, Pater, die Aussage
gibt's gar nicht, das ist Fake-Grund vom Chef, ja, das siehst du mal, das daran sieht
man, wenn du, wenn du, wenn er euch halt irgendwie nicht traut, was halt merkwürdig ist, weil
gerade als Chef solltest du eigentlich erkennen können, in der Lage sein zu erkennen, was
deine Leute machen und, äh, wenn das Homeoffice-mäßig auch klappt, dann ist doch gut.
Jetzt, Wodafone, komm mach hinne.
Max, kennst du dich mit Container-Networking aus? Also mit dem Standard-Docker-Zeug schon?
So halbwegs, was man halt so braucht? Je nachdem, was du machen willst, also wenn du jetzt diesen
Cisco, Cisco-Firmware-Emulator da irgendwie in der VM laufen lassen willst, mit 48 Interfaces
im Container laufen lassen willst, da kann ich ja nicht sagen, wie das geht. Also den
kann man übrigens gar nicht im Container laufen lassen, fällt mir ein.
Äh, warum 48 FPS für die cineastische Experience? 48 FPS ist ganz einfach zu erklären. 48 FPS
ist deutlich flüssiger als 30 und sieht schärfer aus bei der gleichen Bandbreite wie 60.
Meine Güte, Wodafone, ey. Ich kann so nicht weitermachen.
Ich kann so nichts machen, wenn der Kack nicht funktioniert.
Soll ich dir mal einen OpenVPN-Server in Frankfurt, Niederlande aufsetzen? Hilft es gegen Kack-Wodafone-Peering?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das hilft. Ich wollte das auch schon mal ausprobieren,
ich wollte mir mal bei einfach bei DigitalOcean eine Kiste holen und dann VPN hin machen und
gucken, ob es funktioniert dann mit Wodafone, aber ich, ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich
sicher, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Dein Tweet bezüglich Leute, die zuhause was machen oder nicht stimmt 200%.
Ich finde es schön, wenn sich das auch mit deiner Erfahrung deckt. 8,6% Frame Loss.
Was ist mit Wodafone, was machen die eigentlich mit ihrem Netzwerk?
Hat er den Switch aufgemacht und erstmal irgendwie reingespuckt?
Was machen die da?
Ja Pater, das wäre ja auch komplett unsinnig, wozu braucht man das 24-7?
Welcher Zwischenspeicher kann eigentlich voll offenbar dieser Unity Media Connect Box
sein?
Hat das jemand von Wodafone erzählt oder was?
Ich wüsste nicht, was da groß voll laufen soll, ich meine, wenn du irgendwelche Buffer
hast, die können natürlich immer voll laufen, wenn es dann schnell genug wegkommt auf der
anderen Seite.
Das ist aber nicht das Problem von der Connect Box oder von dem Buffer, irgendwie sind Buffer
halt voll.
Und es bringt ja auch nichts drei Stunden da irgendwas drin zu speichern, wenn das zu
einer aktiven Verbindung gehört, das braucht dann keiner mehr, wenn es nach drei Stunden
ankommt.
Das liegt einfach an anderen Stellen, da kann man daheim nichts machen.
7, 8, das ist ja immer noch am abkacken, 10% fast.
Ach stimmt, das habe ich ganz vergessen, die 48 FPS liegen ja auch daran, weil jedes Auge
nur 24 FPS sehen kann, natürlich, exellent.
Wobei, ne, es waren 12 FPS pro Auge, wie kann man das dann erklären?
Wie kommen bei dir die Bilder mit den Memelinks im Bild, hier vorn, da, ich habe mir sowas
programmiert, wo man Zeug einblenden kann hier, so nicht der Gaben, der könnte uns
jetzt mal helfen, dass Wodafone nicht mehr so leckt, oder Hackermans haben wir auch hier,
aber Achtung Leute, äh, Passt, äh, also, Warnung, jetzt wird es laut, spielst du noch
Overwatch?
Ne, das letzte halbe Jahr nicht mal angefasst.
JSPP64 schreibt von seinen Freunden, er hört immer noch schlechte Sachen über Wodafone,
ich höre auch selten Gutes von Wodafone, allerdings ist es bei mir der beste Anbieter,
was Upload und Download angeht, Telekom kann da nicht in ähnliche Regionen mithalten,
leider, sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch gar kein Wodafone.
Aber ich werde das jetzt jeden Stream so machen, wenn die rumleggen, das dauert ja meistens
gar nicht so lang, und das ist ja auch meistens nur so einmal richtig pro Stream.
Ähm, ich lass einfach jetzt immer den Scheißhaufen von Wodafone auf, bis ich das nach 10 Minuten
wieder erledigt hab, mir bleibt eh nix anderes übrig, ich hab ja mal, ich hab's euch ja
erzählt, ich hab den Wodafone-Support angeschrieben, und der Wodafone-Support hat mir dann unterm
Strich gesagt, ich soll die SSID von meinem Wlan ändern, da sieht man mal, was da für
Spezialisten sitzen.
Flame mal etwas auf Twitter, das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Die reagieren zwar schnell, aber passiert halt nix, die Anbindung von denen wahrscheinlich
irgendwo in Frankfurt oder so, das ist halt einfach grottenschlecht.
Guck mal, ah nee, geht, geht trotzdem nicht.
Der hat bei mir das, bei Void-Danny sagt, bei ihm hat der Wodafone-Mitarbeiter genau
das gleiche erzählen, ja, das scheint wohl so ne Standardantwort zu sein, ändern sie
mal ihre SSIDs.
Ja gut, 1&1 ist ja auch wirklich Bullshit, also wenn schon Telekom Resale, dann halt
auch gleich Telekom und nicht Resale.
Wann kommt ein Video über deinen neuen Server rum, der so neu ist, hat da gar nix.
Der neue Server steht immer noch hier links neben mir auf der Erde.
Wir haben 10% geschafft, Leute.
Yeah!
Ähm, ich stelle mal kurz die Bitrate ein bisschen runter, vielleicht bringt das ja
was.
Nö, das ist immer noch, 2 Mbit ist 2,9 Mbit ist immer noch zu viel anscheinend.
Oh, wir haben 11% geschafft, sehr gut, exquisite, Wodafone exquisite, ok, Achtung, 1,9, ok,
2,9.
Jetzt haben wir 2 Mbit noch übrig, 2 Mbit, komm Wodafone, 2 Mbit schafft ihr, da geht
außer Sound kaum noch was durch, in anehmbarer Qualität gerade.
Na, 2 Mbit scheint zu funktionieren, hä?
Was ist das für ein Scheiß, Alter?
Was die Soundbitrate ist da nicht drinnen, warum steht da da total, das ergibt jetzt
da eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Es ist, ach Gott, ey, 101,3 Mbit und es geht nicht ordentlich durch, ich kriege Anfälle
Wodafone.
Läufst du am Montag mit deiner Metromaske rum, wieso am Montag, ist da Maskenpflicht
oder was, ich weiß, ich hab noch keine News gelesen heute, also wer die Metromaske noch
nicht kennt, ich zeig sie euch nochmal, meine Metromaske, was, warum kann ich meine eigenen,
meine eigenen, ach Gott, Twitter, alle, warum gängeln die ein, alle immer so, warum gängeln
die ein, alle so, wo ist denn mein Bild, wo ist das Bild von meiner Maske, Twitter, noch
nicht mal Twitter lädt, ich hab was von Metro geschrieben dabei, hier, ah, meine Metromaske,
WTF Trending, was ist Trending, Kim Jong Un dead, was, Kim Jong Un ist dead, das ist
doch fake oder, ja was denn du, stimmt das jetzt oder nicht, ok, da kann man, Twitter,
Twitter kann man nicht glauben, Kim, ah, ihr, ne, da ist anscheinend nichts dran, unbestätigt,
ja, dead, ist er geplatzt oder was, naja, mal gucken, wird, wird die nächsten Tage schon
rauskommen, was kommt denn als nächstes, wir werden jetzt Kim Jong Un, davor hatten
wir Kim Jong Il, davor hatten wir Kim, wie ist der andere, ach kein Schimmer, jetzt kommt
Kim Jong Un, oder so kommt jetzt, Maskenpflicht, steht das hier, ja, stimmt, da wollte ich jetzt
gerade mal gucken, was, Maskenpflicht, wisst ihr was ich geil finde, warte mal, wisst ihr
was ich lustig finde, also, am Anfang, wo alle noch gesagt haben, ach Lull ist doch
nicht so schlimm, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, auf Twitter, wo alle gesagt haben,
ach was, was interessiert es mich, ah Krippe ist doch viel schlimmer, es ist doch gar nicht
so wild, ist doch alles toll und zu diesem Zeitpunkt, waren ja auch die Leute am Start,
die alle dann kamen so, siehst du, und Masken bringen doch eh nix, und es ist auch fragwürdig,
was Masken bringen, also, das klang schon glaubwürdig, was damals die Leute erzählt
haben, die sich damit auskennen, Kim kommt um, das ist so geil, so, und Masken komplett
overrated, brauchen wir alles nicht, Masken brauchen wir, total schwachsinnig, Masken
bringen eh nix, Masken schützen nicht, so, dann haben wir angefangen, das alles ein
bisschen runter zu fahren, das lief auch ganz gut, und jetzt fahren wir das ganze wieder
an, und, weil die Leute nicht in der Lage sind, weil die Leute teilweise auch zu degeneriert
im Kopf sind, sich irgendwie halbwegs dran zu halten, dass man ein bisschen Abstand hält,
dass man in Geschäften irgendwie sich was umzieht, jetzt sollen wir überall Masken
aufziehen, die ja angeblich, wie es am Anfang gesagt hat, nix bringen, also, rein irgendwo
am Arsch der Welt, im Freien, brauche ich keine Maske, das ist kompletter Schwachsinn,
im Geschäft, vollkommen okay, den mega Upload Song, warum denn den mega Upload Song, du
meinst, weil es Kim Jong-Kom ist, oder was, okay, also was, was haben wir denn, Ab der
kommende Woche gilt in allen Bundesländern eine Maske nicht, wie diese kontrolliert
und welche Bußgelder bei Missachtung fällig werden wird, ohne dass ihr dich kannt habt.
Ja, ist ja auch klar, die Leute haben sich ja auch absolut nicht dran gehalten, ich hab
ein Foto, ich muss euch das mal zeigen, jetzt wird's wieder schwierig mit Upload, ich hoffe
man erkennt's, ich hab ein Foto am Main gemacht, über den Main weg halt, Moment, was hatten
wir letztens für eine Seite, um Bilder hochzuladen, wie hieß das, Post Image Punkt, ja genau,
da lad ich, ich lad mal grad was hoch, ich zeig euch mal ein Bild, was ich am Main gemacht
hab, wo es um soziale Distanz und generell Leute gibt, die ein bisschen ihr Hirn einschalten,
und da werdet ihr sehen, dass es halt viel zu viele Falschbasten gibt, die nix hinkriegen.
So, ich hab das Bild mal hochgeladen, so, also, Post Image, ich hoffe man erkennt's,
ich hab das mit meinem alten iPhone aufgenommen, also mit dem 6s, das hat halt keine, oder
hat, nee, 6s ist das glaube ich, das alte auf jeden Fall, das hat halt eine scheiß Kamera-Quali
im Vergleich zu den neuen, aber ich hoffe man erkennt das trotzdem, erkennt man's, guckt
euch mal an, das hab ich über den Main fotografiert aufgenommen, also sprich, ich bin hier gelaufen
auf der Seite, und da drüben ist so ein Strand, seht ihr das am Strand, seht ihr das am Strand,
was da los ist, man erkennt's schlecht, ja, aber, ok, ich geb zu, es ist pixelig, aber
man sollte es eigentlich erkennen, da sitzen Leute, da sitzen Leute, da stehen irgendwie
8 Leute auf einem Haufen, hier stehen auch irgendwie 8 Leute am Haufen, da vorne ist
ein Schwan am Start, das ist fast schon ein paar Ding am Strand gewesen, natürlich keiner
Mundschutz auf oder irgendwas, machst du gerne Fotos vom Fremden, nee, mach ich nicht, ich
mach nur Fotos von Sachen, die mich aufregen, und das ist ne Sache, die mich aufregt, also
mir kann jetzt aber keiner erzählen, dass er hier irgendwelche Leute erkennen würde,
ja, also eindeutig hier, den da, den im Busch, den erkennt man zu gut, da muss ich den schwarzen
Balken drüber machen, naja, so, also was, wo ohne Maske Bußgel droht, da bin ich mal
gespannt jetzt, stimmt, da hinten ist der Kabum irgendwo gewesen, Quatsch ey Leute,
also DSGVO, ab der kommenden Woche geht alles, wie diese kontrolliert wird und welche Bußgel
dabei ist, also ich hab die Polizei bei uns am Main schon gesehen, aber noch nie hat irgendwie
einer was gesagt, angeblich haben die bei uns irgendwo im Nachbarort am Friedhof ne Party
von Jugendlichen, am Friedhof, ne Party von 20 Jugendlichen aufgelöst, letztes Wochenende,
am Friedhof, die haben wahrscheinlich gedacht, das sieht keiner, also wer sich drauf verlässt
und wer Hoffnung hatte, dass die Leute freiwillig und mit Hirn einschalten was machen, ist eh
komplett hängen geblieben, ok Moment, das ist, warum ist der Scheiß immer so kompliziert,
können die nicht einfach sagen, ja, gilt, wenn du dagegen verstößt in dem und dem
Gebiet, dann, keine Ahnung, 200 Euro Geldstrafe, du musst dir immer, dass du die Sachen in
Deutschland kapierst, musst du dir immer 5 Seiten durchlesen und hoffen, dass du nicht
zufällig über die Grenze in Bayern fährst, wo die Sachen wieder komplett anders sind,
ok also hoffen wir mal, Berlin juckt mich nicht, Hessen, was ist Hessen, Hessen, 50 Euro,
weißt du was ich mache, Leute wisst ihr was, wisst ihr was ich am Montag mache, das nehme
ich auf, das nehme ich auf mit der Kamera, ich gehe am Montag auf die Sparkasse Geld
abheben und guck mal ob die mich reinlassen, mit meiner Maske, das nehme ich auf im Handy,
mal gucken was passiert, mal gucken ob die mich rauslassen, weil bei der Sparkasse hängt
immer noch das Schild vorne dran, dass man nicht mit Motorradhelm rein darf, ich meine
das ist, das ist, streng genommen ist das kein Motorradhelm, die denken ja du bist Bankro,
wahrscheinlich denke ich mit Bankro, wiederholte Verstöße mit einem, die gehen mir jetzt
so auf den Sack, wenn ich am Main spazieren gehe und ich bin ja jemand der achtet auf
Abstand, ich ziehe mir auch öfters mein Hemd über die Nase wenn es mal wieder einer nicht
macht, ok dafür ist, aber ich versuche wirklich riesen Bogen um die Leute zu machen, ich glaube
nicht, dass wenn ich am Main mal kurz spazieren gehe, dass ich da irgendwie Leute gefährde
und gefährdet bin, das ist einfach ätzend, die gehen mir auf den Keks jetzt, hat eigentlich
irgendwie einer Plan da, wie man sowas managen sollte, nicht dass ich es wüsste, an mir
kommt es irgendwie so vor, als machen wir einfach nur Aktion nach Aktion nach Aktion
ohne dass die irgendwie zusammenhängen, na anscheinend gilt es jetzt überall, das Bundesland
Hessen, wo das Massenpflicht ebenfalls am Montag in Kraft tritt, die gehen mir alles
so auf den Sack, all die Klappe, so Hessen, jetzt heißt es schon mal Hessen, Hessen, Hessen,
diese Solle für Geschäfte A und den öffentlichen Nahverkehr gelten, also jetzt wieder, ok also
jetzt doch nicht oder wie, kannst du wieder 5mbit stellen, hat es aufgehört zu ruckeln,
hat es aufgehört zu ruckeln, ruckelt nicht mehr, stellen wir mal wieder hoch, gucken wir
mal, exzellent, dass es jetzt mal kurz ruckelt, ist normal beim Bandbreiten ändern, aber
jetzt sollte es funktionieren, wenn das wieder hoch geht Leute, ich resette mal die Stats,
dass man das auch sieht, naja, eine seriöse FAQ der hessischen Regierung, ooooh Wahnsinn,
die sind ja schnell, ok, die hessische Landesregierung hat eine Massenpflicht beschlossen, die am
Montag, 27. April gilt, ok, Nahverkehr nutzen oder die Publikationsbereich von Geschäften,
Banken und Postfiltern, das finde ich gut, das ist ok, das scheint mir sinnvoll, das
finde ich ok und wisst ihr was man mal machen müsste, man müsste den Leuten mal erklären,
wie man eine Maske überhaupt richtig aufzieht, ich sehe nämlich ganz viele Leute auch in
Geschäften, die haben die Maske über den Mund und nicht über die Nase, was meinen
die denn warum die so eine Form hat, dass die über Mund und Nase getragen werden kann,
was für eine GPU und CPU hast du in den 8700K, ein bisschen übertakt der 9800HTi, warum
bist du so scharf darauf, dass ich den Mega Upload Song anmache, Leute, Mega Upload Song
oder kein Mega Upload Song, wir hatten den Mega Upload Song schon lange nicht mehr, ok,
Mega Upload Song, wild, big, Battlefield 5 Final, it's over, haha, ok, haltet euch fest,
der Mega Upload Song, da hat der Knäber sogar kleingesubscribed, kommt, dass ich keine Subs
übersehen habe, Vollkorn Mischprode habe ich glaube ich übersehen, danke für den
Tier 1 Sub, 2 Monate, nee, nee, doch, doch, doch, das habe ich gesehen, habe ich gesehen,
alles gut, alles gut, also Mega Upload Song, weil, weil, weil ihr der, seid,
kein Pock, meinetwegen auch ein Pock, ich finde es immer so geil, die, die Typen hatten
alle keinen Plastenschimmer, für was sie sich da in die Kamera gesetzt haben, wer ist
das, den kenne ich, den habe ich schon mal gesehen, die habe ich auch schon mal irgendwo
gesehen, andere kenne ich nicht, warum machen die Künstler werden für Raumkopien, weil
ich keine Ahnung hatten, warum vor sie da vor die Kamera gesessen haben, jetzt muss
er noch selbst singen, der Knäber und das Sebaro, die steigern sich ja richtig rein
gerade, 10 times faster, bit by bit unlimited, it's a hit, warum kann man sich den Kram überhaupt
nicht merken, guck mal Leute, da merkt ihr, dass ihr alt seid, 2011, 9 Jahre ist das her,
übrigens der Frosch ist mein Overlay, das gehört nicht zum Video, hobs, Book Free, Book
Free, wo kommt man eigentlich raus, wenn man auf Mega Upload, nee was war das Punkt, Moment
Leute, ich gehe mal kurz in meine Linux-VM, ich weiß nicht, was muss ich da einfangen,
mega-upload.com war das, nee da gibt es nicht, der Mega NZ ist das Neue, wie lange geht
das eigentlich noch, was macht dann eigentlich gerade so, wie hast du gerade so schnell gewechselt,
hier, Windows-Alt-File-Taste, Achtung Epilepsie-Warnung, was macht der eigentlich gerade, Sam knast
jetzt, ich hoffe nicht, das ist der VM, ja das ist hier VM-Workstation, ich hoffe nicht,
dass er im Knast ist, ja okay, keine Ahnung, was da jetzt gerade rausgekommen ist, ich glaube,
er kehrt schon schon Shrimp-Warrant, alles kurz, ich hoffe, okay, Laddra chaotic, Aa,
Keine Ahnung, was er gerade so treibt.
Na gut, also
FAQ, es betrifft
nur Nahverkehr,
Geschäfte, Banken und Postvieland, das finde
ich sinnvoll.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt,
dass Leute jetzt abgemahnt
werden, die
Atem-
Atemschutzmasken und so
verkaufen oder Schutzmasken verkaufen
und die Schutzmasken und Atemschutzmasken nennen,
obwohl es selbstgenähte Sachen sind,
da werden die abgemahnt, weil das
quasi keine
richtige Atemschutzmaske
ist und sie ja irgendwie
dann auch, was auch immer,
das wettbewerbsmäßig
verstoßen gegen irgendwas.
So ist das in Deutschland.
Du wirst abgemahnt,
wenn du ein paar Masken lest.
Was hältst du vom neuen Zero,
der Export von Apple?
Ich hab's vorhin nur kurz gesehen, das ist das mit den Mails.
Das da.
Das hier.
Das ist so eine typische
Apple, so eine typische IOS-Sicherheitslücke.
Die hatten ja schon öfters Dinger, dass du
per Mails und per iMessage
entweder das
Smartphone zum Absturz
bringen kannst oder
Code einschleusen, was auch immer. Die hatten ja schon ein paar
so Dinger. Ich hoffe nur,
angeblich gibt es keine direkte Gefahr. Aha.
Ich hoffe nur, die kriegen das gebacken.
Zack Ops
hat's entdeckt.
Okay, Zack Ops ist auch
gut.
Guter Name für eine
Security-Firma. Oder für eine Security-
Gruppe. Zack Ops.
Besonders kritisch.
Die sind alle gerade beschäftigt
mit der Corona-Tracker-App.
Die ja wieder erwartet
total unsicher ist. Wer hätte
das nur gedacht?
Das ist eine App.
Das ist eine offizielle App, die wir
hier in Deutschland basteln, dass die unsicher
ist. Das
wäre mir nie in
Sinn gekommen.
Ja,
da ist es doch. Corona-Tracking-App.
Alleins schon, das kann man
heute mal aussprechen.
P-P-T-P-P-Pepel.
Pep-Pepega.
Pepega-Tracker hätten sie das
nennen sollen.
Ah, ihr habt ja gesehen,
Facebook
hat angeblich
jetzt auch eine
Video-Chat-App vorgestellt
für bis zu, glaub, 50
Leute.
Weil sie festgestellt haben, dass die Leute
alle Zoom verwenden und kein Facebook.
Ich würde weder Zoom noch Facebook
verwenden, wenn ich die Auswahl habe.
Guck mal, wo davon? Kann nicht mehr rum.
Funktioniert.
Eigentlich waren wir ja mal beim Fragen
beantworten irgendwann.
Hast du was von Nintendo Online?
Was? Die Frage ist doch schon
uralt.
Oder ist die? Kam die eben gerade?
Ach, die kam eben gerade.
Ja, habe ich
mitbekommen und ich wollte eigentlich
gucken, ob ich 2-Faktor-
Authentifizierung auf
meinem
Account anhab.
Hab ich aber nicht gemacht.
Passwort?
Nintendo, ey.
Oh Gott, warum seid ihr
so unfähig, was Online angeht?
Ahh.
Warum ist Nintendo so unfähig, was
Online-Sachen angeht?
Es heißt, was ich damit nicht sagen will,
ist, dass das andere nicht so
Was ich damit nicht sagen will, ist, dass das andere nicht auch passiert.
Das passiert, es ist, es ist, Sony ist das schon passiert.
Ähm, sogar ziemlich groß, ich glaube Microsoft auch.
Allen ist das schon irgendwie mal passiert.
Aber Passwort!
Warum speichert man das Passwort überhaupt?
Was ist, was ist mit den Leuten eigentlich los?
Warum speichert man Passwörter?
Es ist doch komplett unsinnig, Passwörter zu speichern.
Braucht kein Mensch, muss Passwörter speichern.
Und dann, und dann auch noch ein Teil unverschlüsselt.
Aber erstmal Plain Text Passwörter.
Das passt aber zu Nintendo.
Letztens im Video gesehen,
das in Animal Crossing, das im neuen Animal Crossing,
dass man, quasi Leute, die mit Passwörtern speichern,
dass man quasi Leute aus seiner Freundesliste
besuchen kann in seinem Dorf.
Allerdings, ist es wohl dann so,
dass wenn der Host oder irgendeiner der Leute,
die die Session gejoint sind, das Menü offen hat,
dann kann niemand mehr die Session verlassen.
Also sprich, wenn ihr jetzt mit ein paar Freunden
irgendwie in Animal Crossing jemand besucht,
und es hat einer von den Leuten, die im gleichen Spiel sind,
das Menü offen, dann könnt ihr das Spiel nicht mehr verlassen.
Exzellent, Nintendo, oder?
Ach ja, und wenn dann jemand Rage quittet über Menü,
wenn dann jemand übers Menü Rage quittet,
verlieren alle, inklusive der Host der Session,
jeglichen Progress, der gemacht wurde.
Das ist wirklich exzellent, Nintendo-Taktik.
Huge, da hat Nintendo mir die ganze Arbeit geleistet,
was das angeht. Mir leuchtet es auch nicht ein,
wie es Nintendo so krass verkacken kann,
über drei Konsolengenerationen hinweg.
Das leuchtet mir nicht ein, wie das geht.
Das ist ja auf der Wii, das war zu Zeiten von der Xbox 360,
also schon nach der ersten Xbox, das war zu Zeiten von der Xbox 360
und der PS3, da war der Online-Modus schon scheiße.
Und da hat man sich gedacht, okay, das ist die erste Online-Konsole,
so richtig von Nintendo, da müssen die erstmal was draus lernen.
Gut, Wii U kam raus, Online-Modus war zum größten Teil auch scheiße.
Switch kommt raus, Online-Modus zum größten Teil auch scheiße.
Was macht Nintendo denn? Wie unfähig kann man sein,
im Jahr 2020 ordentliche Online-Funktionen zu basteln?
Man muss doch gar nichts bahnbrechendes Neues machen.
Man muss einfach nur den Mist nachbauen,
den die anderen schon gemacht haben.
Das heißt, wenn man keinen Plan hat, was man machen soll,
dann klaut man es einfach von Microsoft und Sony
und irgendwelchen x-beliebigen anderen Online-Diensten.
Dann klaut man es einfach.
Dann braucht man auch keine Splatoon-App,
in der man nicht mal Squats bilden kann oder sonst was.
Dann guckt man sich es einfach ab.
Aber Nintendo ist absolut unfähig, was online angeht.
Was ist eigentlich aus Arms geworden, ihrem E-Sport-Competitive-E-Sport-Game?
Nee, das ist was anderes.
Arms League? Hä?
Das ist ein Ingame-Kram.
Das ist ein Ingame-Kram, das hat nichts mit echten Sachen zu tun.
Also sie wollten ja mal hier einen richtig krassen E-Sport starten in Arms.
Das hat halt nicht funktioniert, wahrscheinlich weil der Online-Modus scheiße ist.
Also was wurde denn alles bei Nintendo geleakt?
Nintendo, A Network, Aldi, also alles.
Im Prinzip alles, was drin ist.
Oh, Geschlecht.
Was ist, wenn da ein anderes Geschlecht drin ist,
als ich mich jetzt gerade fühle?
Oh, Nintendo-Anzeige ist raus.
Du bist toll.
Das ist schön, wenn du das so siehst.
Vier Monate in Folge abonniert, nice.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Makes no sense, Dota.
Hyper-Subscriber.
Mich würde interessieren, die meisten anderen veröffentlichen auch ein bisschen was zu.
So, wie ist es dazu gekommen?
Was war?
Okay, Dear Customer.
Ah, excellent.
Wir können uns die japanische Stellungnahme angucken.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, mit welcher E-Mail-Adresse ich überhaupt meinen Nintendo-Account verknüpft habe.
Oh, Beste hier.
Ja, muss ich nachher noch mal gucken nach meinem Nintendo-ACC.
Verknäher, aber ja.
Guck mal, jetzt ist wieder komplett lack-free.
Lack-Fryer.
Ja, Knäher-Beer.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nicht mehr drauf kommen, auf das Ganze, nur weil ich euch mal kurz noch mal meine Maske zeigen wollte.
Die werde ich dann vielleicht am Montag einweihen.
Ich gehe Montag auf die Bank und heb Geld ab.
Mal gucken, ob die mich mit der Maske reinlassen.
Na, eigentlich waren wir mal am Fragen beantworten.
Wir kommen ja gar nicht hinterher, irgendwas zu machen heute.
Hör mal auf, mit dem Thema, da sag ich nichts zu.
Was? Hä? Um was geht's?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, auf was sich diese Frage bezieht.
Ach, Kim dort, komm. Was? Der ist bei Knossi dabei.
Okay, irgendwie passt das zusammen.
Irgendwie passt das sogar gut zusammen.
Irgendwie, irgendwie passen die zusammen, ich weiß nicht.
Was?
Nee, kein Overwatch mehr.
Das hatten wir alle schon.
Das hatten wir doch alle schon.
Hatten wir alle schon.
So, sind wir durch.
Ich wollte euch mal was cooles zeigen, was ich gefunden hab.
Was wir in einem der nächsten Streams ausprobieren müssen.
Zwar hab ich für meine Microcontrollers was gefunden.
Und zwar, es gibt irgendjemand, der hat sich hingesetzt
und hat eine.NET-Implementierung für ESP32 gebastelt.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren in einem der nächsten Streams.
Da kann man wohl die meisten normalen.NET Klassen
und sie scharf verwenden, um einen ESP32 zu programmieren.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das gut funktioniert.
Weil ich hatte heute wieder viel Spaß mit C++.
Ich geh immer schon wieder mega auf den Keks.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich will einen Stream anmachen
und mich ein bisschen auskotze.
Aber ich kann nicht jedes Mal einen Stream machen,
wenn mich C++ nervt.
Weil dann müsste ich ja quasi viermal im Stream
und mich permanent über C++ aufregen.
Das will ja auch keiner sehen, dass ich mich
ganz zeitaufrege.
Du wolltest doch mit uns eine neue Programmiersprache
demnächst lernen.
Ich hab gesagt, wir gucken uns mal
dieses Cobol-Handbuch an da.
Also just for fun, machen wir ein paar kleine Cobol-Sachen.
Da werd ich aber auch kotzen bei.
Das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Wir hatten doch letztens so Learn Cobol.
Wo hatten wir es denn?
Muss ich meinen Browser mal wieder updaten?
Ah, exzellent.
Browser updaten.
Irgendwie hab ich es nicht mehr in der History.
Aber ich hab es mir gebookmarkt
in meiner To-Do-Liste,
was wir im Stream machen wollen.
Eine Woche lang C++ Railstream wäre okay.
Ich hab heut wieder was gelernt,
was mich wieder komplett an C++
hat zweifeln lassen.
Und zwar wollte ich versuchen...
Ich zeig's euch, wir haben sie hier noch auf.
Hier, guckt mal.
Das ist hier der Callback
für den Upload von Updates
übers WLAN.
Und das wollte ich in eine Klasse packen.
Und dann hab ich festgestellt,
dass man Funktionen,
also Methoden einer Klasse
in C++
nicht als normale
Callbacks für C-Funktionen
verwenden kann.
Und ich dachte,
warum war das...
Ich kann die Scharp-Funktionen
als Callbacks für C verwenden.
Warum kann ich keine C++-Methoden
als Callbacks für C verwenden?
Das ist dann wieder
richtig schwer getan.
Und dann suchst du ein paar Stack-Overflow
danach und kriegst wieder 20 Seiten
Templates als Lösung geschickt.
Tim ist die BSF, mir ist auch langweilig.
Ja, dann exzellent.
Das ist hier richtig. Wir können uns zusammen langweilen.
Empfehlung für externe
Festplatte für Backups.
Wie willst du das machen?
Willst du eine externe Festplatte haben, die du einfach per USB
dranstöpselst? Oder willst du irgendein
Netzwerklaufwerk haben?
Was meinst du mit Callback?
Sowas hier.
Also sprich, die Funktion wird aufgerufen,
wenn sich irgendwie einer auf die
Uhr unter
update verbindet. Da wird die Funktion
aufgerufen und das Update
wird durchgeführt. Das ist halt ein
Callback
in diese Funktion.
Die Funktion wird dann aufgerufen, wenn es so weit ist.
Das geht nicht.
Ganz simpel, per USB.
Nee, habe ich jetzt keinen speziellen
Tipp, aber was vor einer
Zeit, der
auf
was war das?
Data Horder.
Das ist manchmal ganz interessant zu lesen.
Das sind dann Leute, wo irgendwie
ihre 5 petabyte
Webcam-Sammlung haben oder so.
Kennt ihr noch den Typ, der
Amazon Unlimited
auch wirklich Unlimited
gemacht hat?
Wie der das gemacht hat?
Das habe ich euch glaube ich schon mal erzählt.
Als Amazon Unlimited
noch wirklich Unlimited war,
wollte halt irgendein Typ,
ich sage gleich was zur Festplatte,
wollte irgendein Typ das Ganze
testen, ob das wirklich Unlimited ist,
was Amazon da sagt.
Und was hat er gemacht? Er konnte ja schlecht
petabyte oder
terabyteweise Daten hochladen.
Funktioniert ja nicht.
Bist du Amazon voll geladen, hast du über deinen
DSL Anschluss, ist ja schon
die Welt zu Ende.
Und dementsprechend ist er hergegangen, hat sich gedacht,
was gibt es im Internet denn massig?
Und da ist er auf Porn gekommen.
Und da hat er was
programmiert auf irgendeinem Server mit einer schnellen
Anbindung, der versucht
hat, jegliche
Livecam
Grills mitzuschneiden und
bei Amazon hochzuladen.
Auf allen möglichen
Livecam Seiten hat er
die Sessions mitgeschnitten
und hat sie bei Amazon hochgeladen.
Und Amazon war wirklich Unlimited.
Amazon hat das nicht gelöscht
und hat ihn nicht geblockt oder sonst was.
Ich persönlich gehe ja davon aus,
dass die Amazon Admins
das
gut fanden und ihn deswegen nicht gebannt
haben.
Die haben wahrscheinlich gedacht, endlich
haben wir hier was zu tun, wenn wir die ganze
Zeit auf unser Monitoring gucken und nichts passiert.
So.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Festplatte.
Genau, hier bei Dataorder habe ich letztens was gesehen.
Externe Festplatten, wo man die
wobei das
ist jetzt eher interessant, wenn man
sich in Last bauen will, externe Festplatten,
die man günstiger bekommt, als die Festplatte,
die drin ist. Klingt jetzt erstmal
merkwürdig, aber war so.
Also sprich, es gab externe
Laufwerke,
die günstiger waren, als
die Festplatten, die drin waren. Und da konnte
man sich wunderbar die Platten rausrippen.
Wäre vielleicht auch für dich eine Option,
wenn du schon einen USB-Festplatten
Wechselrahmen oder sowas hast.
Aber ansonsten,
jetzt wirklich ein Tipp,
für eine USB-Festplatte habe ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber ich glaube, man kann da
ehrlich, ich glaube, man kann da auch gar nicht
so viel verkehrt machen.
Ich würde einfach nur gucken, was gerade
die günstigste Terabyte zu Cent ist
und mir davon was kaufen.
Was Funktionen im Konstrakte
und dir fehlt der Rückgabewert oder wie?
Was?
Hast du dir schon
Diret X 12 Ultimate
angeschaut? Nee, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es von
3D-Frameworks jetzt auch
Ultimate Editions gibt. Wann gibt es denn Diret X
Season Pass
oder so?
Ja, genau, Sebaro, sowas.
Der Sebaro hat mal wieder hier
den Link am Start.
Genau sowas hier.
Wie sehr sich das jetzt
lohnt, weiß ich nicht. Muss man mal sich genau angucken.
Aber da gibt es ab und zu mal
Angebote. Da sind die externen Festplatten günstiger
als das, was drin ist. Und man
kriegt, man spart dann irgendwie 30 Euro am Ende
oder so.
USB-Festplatte
ist viel zu langsam. Nö, wenn man USB...
Also alles ab USB 3 ist
erträglich.
Und jetzt kommt mir nicht mehr die
Diskussion, was jetzt für ein USB 3.
3.0, 3.1, 3.2,
Gen 2x2,
Gen 2x1, Gen 2x3,
3x1.
Alles ab USB 3.
Alles, was einen blauen
Stecker hat, ist okay.
Frag nicht, was für USB. USB 3.2,
Gen 2x2.
Nee, es ist USB 3.2,
Gen 2x2. Ich glaube das
Gen 2 kommt an der Stelle weg.
Es gibt ja auch USB
3.2,
Gen 1,
2x1.
Ich habe da mal irgendwann ein Video drüber gemacht,
dass das USB-Cremium
absolut Dachschaden
hat, was
die Benahmung angeht und anscheinend
haben es mittlerweile auf 50.000 Leute geguckt.
Okay, nice.
Haben mir 50.000 Leute zugehört,
fühle ich mich über das USB-Forum aufregelt.
Ich glaube, dass das USB-Forum
und das C++-Cremium,
dass da große Überschneidungen sind,
was die Leute angeht.
3K-Likes und rein
auf 50.000 Likes.
Was soll ich heute machen?
Außer euch mit sinnlosen
sinnlosen Emotes voll zu spammen.
DirectX 10 Ultimate.
Was ist DirectX 12 Ultimate?
Na, dann Java im Leben nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, C++ war ich heute immer.
Announcing DirectX
12 Ultimate.
Das ist ein April-Scherz.
Nee, ist es nicht.
We are beyond pleased.
Oh, das klingt
ja mal wieder.
Auf meine Ideen ist,
ich habe meine Notizen nicht gesunken.
Ich sehe sie gerade nicht.
Also im Prinzip
hätte man das Ganze auch
13 nennen können, oder?
Aber Microsoft hat es ja
mit Benamen nicht.
Übrigens noch mal eine richtige Pepega-Sache,
was Microsoft-Benamung angeht.
Die hatten ja früher
das ganz normale.NET-Framework.
Das ist ja deprecated
im Endeffekt und jetzt gibt es ja.NET Core.
So, und Microsoft hat sich jetzt
überlegt, sie hatten jetzt.NET Core
1.1.1.2.2.1.3.
Also immer.NET Core.
Alles gut von der Benamung her.
1.0.1.2.0.2.1.2.2.3.0.3.1
So, und das nächste ist.NET
5.
Die lassen das Core wieder weg.
Und dann ist es jetzt.NET 5.
Was übelst verwirrend ist, weil das.NET
Framework war, die letzte Version,
4.8.
Und.NET 5
hat mit dem.NET Framework
4.8 nichts zu tun.
Und auch im Prinzip
ist.NET 5 der Nachfolger
von.NET Core 3,
wo man das Core aber weglässt.
Und wo es noch verwirrender wird, ist
ihr Datenbank-Zugriffs-Framework.
Das heißt ja aktuell Entity Framework Core.
Immer mit der gleichen Version
wie.NET.
Also sprich aktuell heißt es
dann Entity Framework Core 3.
Und dann haben sie sich jetzt
überlegt, sie nennen das dann
in.NET 5, nennen sie das dann auch wieder
Entity Framework 5.
Und der Witz ist, dass das
ganz, ganz alte Entity
Framework im alten
.NET Framework hieß 6.
Das heißt wir haben
.NET 5, was mit
.NET Framework 4.8 nichts
zu tun hat. Und wir haben Entity
Framework 6, wir haben
Entity Framework 5, was
jetzt nach Entity Framework
6 rauskommt, aber neuer
ist und auf anderer Sache basiert.
Was ist mit Microsoft
los?
Die haben sie nämlich alle, was
das angeht. Wie bescheuert kann man eigentlich
sein?
Was soll man von einer Firma
erwarten, die Windows 9 übersprungen hat?
Naja, dass man Windows 9
übersprungen hat, wenigstens ging es
aufwärts mit der Zahl.
Und nicht wie bei Battlefield von 4 auf 1.
Ist doch alles voll logisch.
Also wer das logisch findet, findet auch die Battlefield
Benamung logisch und die Xbox Benamung
logisch.
Aber das ist wirklich, das ist
komplett, einfach nur total
hängen geblieben.
Guck mal, was Heise dazu schreibt.
Ultimate.
Ok, das ist im Prinzip, im Prinzip
scheint es wahrscheinlich, Dialog X 12.1
oder sowas zu sein.
Gut, da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Wie gesagt, ich sag's ja jedes Mal,
ich bin nicht der große
Grafikprogrammierer.
Das Einzige, was ich mal in 3D gemacht
hab, was man 3D,
nur einsatzweise 3D nennen kann,
ist die T-Kanne in OpenGL,
diese Standard, die Standard T-Kanne,
den Standard Teapot in OpenGL
einmal zu rendern.
Mit Rust.
Ich hab mir ein Rust OpenGL Tutorial angeguckt.
So die Standard,
Standard T-Kanne,
die kennt glaube ich jeder, der ein bisschen
was mit Grafik Sachen gemacht hat,
die Standard T-Kanne.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum,
warum ausgerechnet eine T-Kanne.
Keine Ahnung.
Und ansonsten
hab ich mit Dialog X eigentlich nur 2D
Sachen gemacht.
Video rescalen
und so Sachen, aber
nie
irgendwelche großartige
3D-Programmiergeschichten.
Und was ist mit 0.3D?
0.3D ist, ich weiß,
es ist schwer zu glauben,
aber 0.3D ist bloß eine Illusion.
Das ist gar nicht wirklich 3D.
Schau dir mal die Proposals
für C-Sharp 9 an,
das ist eine gute Idee.
Oho!
Das ist,
das, das machen wir,
das machen wir wirklich mal.
Ähm,
das ist eine gute Idee.
Gerade mal kurz gucken, dass ich keine Fragen
über sehen hab.
Ich glaube in der Seite haben sie wahrscheinlich
Sachen drinnen.
Steht doch hier, hier, Candidate für 9.0.
Bei C-Sharp geht's wenigstens.
Da heißt der Kram wenigstens
immer aufsteigend.
Brauchst du ein Clear All?
Tatsächlich, aber ich hab keinen Bock
das Programm mehr anzufassen.
Per zu wechseln, ne.
Wieso ist C++
die beste Programmiersprache?
Das ist, also, das ist so offensichtlicher
Gebate.
Da geh ich nicht drauf ein.
Ne,
hab ich nicht. Ich warte bis es auf den PC
kommt, dann vielleicht.
Hast du schon Abend gegessen? Ja, hab ich.
Hab ich schon ganz am Anfang erzählt.
Ich hab den ganzen Tag nichts gegessen
und Abend erst mal 6 Toastbrote.
Huge, gesunde,
wahnsinnig gesunde Toastbrote.
3x Nutella, 3x Erdnussbutter.
Hast du ein Laptop favorit mit Linux?
Hm.
Ich hab nur auf den Notebooks das ganze
ausprobiert, die wir auf der Arbeit haben.
Ich hab ja privat seit Jahren schon kein Notebook
mehr. Ich hab
einen alten AMD Notebook,
das ist aber schon 10 Jahre alt oder so.
Da ist auch noch ein Ubuntu, frag mich nicht,
1404 oder sowas drauf.
Oder noch 1204 oder
sowas.
Und
auf der Arbeit haben wir
Lenovo Thinkpads.
Da funktioniert's wunderbar.
Du kannst mein Tool nicht
crashen.
Das eskept ordentlich.
Und es haben wir auch schon versucht,
Leute zu injecten und sonst was.
Ich hab ordentlich eskept.
Funktioniert nicht.
Ganz ein mächtigeren Twitch Chat Hacker hier.
Hacker Mans.
Hotkey zum Desktop wechseln.
Steuerung, Windows,
File, äh äh,
Windows-File-Taste.
Doch, Patrick,
ISC eskept mit Sicherheit das Meiste.
Garantiert.
Ok, also, C Sharp 9 Proposals.
Was haben wir da so zu bieten?
Ok, ich lese mir jetzt nicht die
Originalsachen durch, weil da sind wir
lange beschäftigt. Wir gucken uns
die Zusammenfassung an.
Was? Diskriminierte Vereinigung.
Was ist da los?
Microsoft Anzeige ist raus.
Ok, also, Records.
Was gibt's an Records
Neues?
Er ist anscheinend ganz
außer sich, dass das ein ganz tolles neues
Feature ist.
Wat?
Ok, der Artikel
ist ein bisschen wehgeschrieben. Gucken wir uns mal
Code an. Record
would be Public Class.
Warum
nehme ich da nicht einfach einen Struct?
Wenn ich sowas haben will?
Weil man es
Read-Only haben will, oder was?
Keine Ahnung, was das mir sagen soll.
Checker nicht.
F-Sharp kommt jetzt.
Jetzt wollte ich es aber wissen.
Das ist mir zu abstrakt.
Ich will mal irgendwie ein paar ordentliche
Targetar-
Oh, was ist das?
Neue Operators sind immer gut.
It's, was?
A low implicit conversion from null?
Was?
Ok, was? Moment, was macht das?
Ah, heißt das, ne
heißt das wenn, das gibt's doch schon.
Das, gibt's das
nicht schon?
Oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Oder ist das JavaScript, wo es das schon gibt?
Gibt's das nicht schon?
Also im Prinzip
ist das wahrscheinlich
wenn die Liste
null ist,
dann leg
eine neue Liste an.
So verstehe ich das jetzt.
Also sollte es-
Ach nee, hier unten ist das Beispiel
für C-Sharp 9.
Ah, ok,
man kann jetzt
das Initialisieren kürzer schreiben.
Das ist cool.
Was? Ok, das kann man
verkürzen zu so?
Oh, das finde ich auch ganz nice.
Weil das Handling
von KeyValue hat sich schon immer ein bisschen
eklig angefühlt.
Schau dir mal Parameter Null Checking
an. Steht das hier drinnen?
Gucken wir mal, C-Sharp 9.
Ganz unten?
Ja, gut, da kommen wir gleich noch dazu.
Ok, das ist ganz
praktisch, finde ich.
Man hätte aber
auch, hätte man nicht einfach
hätte man das nicht einfach noch kürzer
machen können?
Dass man das einfach weglässt?
Dass man so die Ruby Syntax nimmt?
Ähm, quasi
sowas hier in der Richtung?
Wobei, das wäre wahrscheinlich kollidiert
mit der Lambda Syntax.
Ich glaube, das hätte nicht so gut
funktioniert.
Ja, wahrscheinlich doch so ist
äh
C-Sharpiger.
C-Rautemäßiger.
C-Hashtag.
Ne.
Ok, das ist
gewöhnungsbedürftig erstmal.
Das ist mir jetzt zu lang, da platzt mein Kopf.
Das kriege ich nicht verarbeitet gerade.
Aber das finde ich cool hier.
Da kann man sich halt sparen, dass man
jetzt schreibt New Point.
Schreibt man einfach New
und der checkt, was man für eine
Klasse haben will, mit dem jeweiligen
passenden Constructor, weil hier
aber was wahrscheinlich nicht geht
was wahrscheinlich nicht geht
ist dann das hier, ne?
Das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht gehen.
Weil
woher soll er wissen, was es ist?
Das wäre natürlich hier Trick 17
übelst Magic, wenn das irgendwie
gehen würde, aber ich wüsste nicht, wie das
funktionieren soll.
Caller Expression Attribute. Was?
Das ist bestimmt für irgendwelche
Debug-Zwecke, dass man sieht, wer wo
was aufgerufen hat.
Äh, ich glaube Feature habe ich noch nie
verwendet bisher.
Das hier.
Ach, ich glaube, ich habe noch nicht einmal probiert.
What?
Public Ref Partial Struct
Haben wir das hier?
Habe ich auch noch nie verwendet?
Ich sehe, ich muss mal
mit den neuen C Sharp Features
beschäftigen.
Ich habe irgendwie die meisten davon noch gar nicht
benutzt.
Das letzte
massiv hilfreiches
C Sharp Feature
war für mich der hier.
Dieser Null
Check Operator hier, keine Ahnung.
String, was auch immer,
Punkt, blub.
Der dann checkt, ob das Null ist.
Das fand ich schon
echt hilfreich.
Das war das letzte richtige, wo ich gesagt habe, oh geil,
das bringt richtig was. Die neue
Pattern-Matching-Geschichte war auch cool.
Erklär das
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen.
So wie ich das verstanden habe, ist
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen. Also wenn ich hier
sowas habe.
Noch mal kurz Zwischen Studio Code
auf.
Neu.
Stellen wir das Ganze mal auf
C Hashtag.
Also wenn ich hier
sowas habe,
irgendeine Liste,
eine Liste,
so und
die will ich zuweisen.
Oder ich will irgendeine Variable zuweisen.
Also Temp.
Ich habe eine Liste
und die Liste ist Null.
Dann nimmt er das, was auf der rechten Seite steht.
Also quasi hier sowas.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Ich hoffe, dieser Tag ist richtig.
Also der guckt dann quasi, ob
die Liste Null ist.
Was interessant wäre, ist, ob die Liste
Null oder leer sein kann.
Wahrscheinlich muss hier wirklich Null sein.
Also sprich, der guckt, ob die Liste
Null ist. Und wenn die Liste
Null ist, macht er eine neue default Liste.
Ich hätte wetten können, das gab es schon.
Ja, das ist ganz praktisch.
Parameter Null Checking.
Ist das das, was ich mir angucken sollte?
Oh!
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz cool.
Hello, simplifying
Standard Null Validation
Das ist cool!
Das ist super!
Das gefällt mir!
Gerade jetzt,
wo sie
das Feature
eingeführt haben, dass man...
Wow, fuck, wo bin ich jetzt?
Da sie mit der letzten
C Sharp Version eingeführt haben,
dass, wenn man Opt-in
ist auf
Null, dass man
dann hier was angezeigt kriegt, wenn man es nicht gekennzeichnet hat.
Das finde ich cool.
Das finde ich echt nice. Das gefällt mir.
Weil man muss sonst
so viele unsinnige Null Checks
machen. Im Prinzip ist ja unter der Haube
also man könnte sagen, ist kein großer Akt.
Es steht dann explizit da.
Und explizit ist ja eh besser, weil man kann es sehen.
Aber das ist auch explizit,
wenn man weiß, was es macht. Das finde ich cool.
Das gefällt mir.
Skip Locals in it.
Was?
Moment, das geht doch jetzt schon.
Ach nee!
Das ist neu. Ah!
Das ist praktisch. Das ist echt praktisch.
Ähm, aktuell
ist es so, wenn ich
keine Ahnung, ich habe eine
Liste.
Ich habe eine Liste.
Und ich sag jetzt irgendwie in der Liste
ähm
machen wir mal Pseudo. Sword.
So, dann
ähm
Sword ist ein doofes Beispiel.
Äh, was gibt's da für
schönes?
Ja genau, ich mach Sword.
Sword kriegt
zwei Parameter.
Da muss man glaube ich bisher so machen, wenn man
beides diskaten will.
Wenn man jetzt
die Werte diskaten will, kann man anscheinend
Anderscore, Anderscore machen.
Das ist eigentlich, kann man, ja, das
finde ich eigentlich ganz nett.
Wenn das das ist, was ich, wenn ich das so verstanden habe.
Prime Sub, der Felix sagt
Hallo, moin Felix.
Huge Sub.
Wie stellt zum Beispiel Studio Code die
Programmiersprecher hier ohne? Da, da gibt's einen Knopf für.
Speicher will ich
Minecraft nicht.
Scheint ein ganz
nettes Feature zu sein.
Attributes on
Local Functions. Äh, ich hab noch nicht einmal
Local Functions verwendet.
Finde ich sieht auch echt eklig
aus. So
Nested Functions in Functions.
C++20
C++20 ist so ein
Clusterfuck. Ja.
C++ allgemein ist
ein Clusterfuck.
Wie gesagt, Patrick,
ich hab ja vorhin wieder gelernt, wo ich ein bisschen vor dem Stream
rumgebastelt hab, dass man
ähm,
Methoden aus der C++
Klasse nicht als
Function Pointer verwenden kann.
Also wenn ich hier so Oldschool
Callbacks hab, so wie hier,
dann kann ich dort nicht einfach
ähm, ne
ne, ne, ne Klassenmethode
reinstecken oder so. Das funktioniert nicht.
Weil Klassenmethoden komplett anders implementiert
sind, wie so normale C-Funktionen anscheinend.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Native
Inns.
Okay, das
weiß ich nicht,
wie sinnvoll das ist.
In manchen Anwendungsgebieten bestimmt.
Stimmt, das geht
nur, wenn sie Static sind, was aber
irgendwie doof ist. Dann kann die ganzen
Klassenkram auch weglassen.
Function Pointers. Uah! Wo was grad
hatten davon? Haben die meine Gedanken
gelesen grad oder was?
Haben die grade meine Gedanken
gelesen? Ich hab grad was von ekligem
Function Pointer in C++ erzählt und jetzt
hier um die Ecke Function Pointers.
Das ist bestimmt gut, wenn man irgendwie
C-Interop machen will.
Oh, wenn ich sowas schon sehe hier.
Das ist wahrscheinlich für Interop
mit C ganz praktisch, kann ich mir
vorstellen.
Ja, sind doch ein paar coole
Sachen dabei.
Ja, mit dem Ausrufezeichen finde ich
das eine sehr coole Geschichte, das gefällt mir
richtig gut.
Was? Primary Constructors, das haben wir
bei dem anderen nicht gesehen.
Was macht das?
Hä?
Das ist doch nicht so einfach.
Das ist doch schon immer so.
Ah!
Oh, cool!
Das finde ich, das finde ich nice.
Weil oftmals macht man nur
einen Constructor, einzig und allein,
aus dem Grund,
um ein paar
Parameter zu speichern.
Das ist cool.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Ich meine, noch cooler wäre,
wenn man gar keinen Constructor mehr bräuchte.
Aber dann ist schwierig,
welche Properties soll er als
Parameter nehmen?
Das geht dann nicht. Aber das ist
praktisch.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir.
Ja, Record Classes habe ich
bei dem anderen nicht gecheckt, das war mir zu
Expanded, Extended Brain.
Bin ich eigentlich der Einzige,
der solche Artikel nicht liest, sondern
sich nur die Code Samples anguckt?
Du hast letztens Go geflammt
gegen C-Aufrufen, aber das geht nicht gut.
Also das Aufrufen geht halbwegs.
Dazu kommt erstens, dass man
im Mission Studio Code für Go
komplett breakt, wenn du C-Go verwendest.
Und die Performance, das ist auch
mein hauptsächliches Problem, weil ich das für jeden
Frame aus dem Video mache.
Der Overhead
zwischen
C und Go wechselt.
Guck mal hier.
170 Nanosekunden
pro Funktionsaufruf, Overhead obendrauf.
Ich glaube mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen besser, aber das ist der Bits.
Aber schön ist es trotzdem nicht,
auch die ganze Interop-Geschichte an sich
ist sehr hakelig.
Für einfache Sachen geht es ganz
gut, ja. Der Support ist mittlerweile
auch bei Go
ganz okay. Das generiert ja
beispielsweise die C-Header-Files,
die du brauchst, doch gleich mit.
Aber gerade der Performance-Overhead
ist halt abartig groß.
Und was auch ein bisschen kompliziert ist, ist
die Qualitätsverwaltung.
C-Bindings
für eine Library, ja wahrscheinlich
könnte ich mir sogar vorstellen, dass das relativ...
Das geht einfach, ja das geht einfach.
C-Bindings für die Library.
Das geht einfach.
Da musst du einfach hier drüber schreiben
Export, blablub,
und schon hast du eine
Schnittstelle
für C-Zu-Go-Funktion.
Das geht einfach, ja.
Dafür ist es gut.
Aber insgesamt
ist es scheiße.
.NET 5 hat auch Java-Interop.
Echt?
Ja endlich.
Ich konnte es kaum erwarten. Wobei das ganz cool
ist. Also je nachdem wie gut
das funktioniert, ist das wirklich nicht
schlecht. Es gibt
doch ein paar Projekte in Java,
die vielleicht ganz nützlich sind.
Müsste ich mir mal
anschauen.
Und wie machen die das?
Exposen die Java
als C-Sachen
und rufen das von C-Sharp aus. Und wie machen die
den Interop? Ist der halbwegs schnell
zwischen.NET und Java?
Müsste ich mir mal angucken.
Wenn es rauskommt.
Also das fand ich eigentlich ganz nice hier.
Das da, das gefällt mir, das Feature.
Record Class, das war mir zu
big, ist mein Brain gerade zu
low, dass ich das checke.
Das ist mir auch zu kompliziert gewesen.
Aber es waren ein paar coole Sachen dabei.
Das mag ich
auch an C-Sharp, bzw.
an dem Produkt, wie das Microsoft
handelt. Oder von den Leuten,
die das machen. Das ist ja grad der,
das ist irgendein Norweger oder so.
Also der Heilsberg war ja ursprünglich
der Erfinder. Wie heißt denn der?
Der aktuelle C-Sharp. Jetzt heißt er irgendwie Metz.
Metz. Und dann irgendwie
skandinavischer Name.
Und wie die das handeln, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Die entwickeln das kontinuierlich weiter,
immer so ein bisschen in die Richtung,
was halt gerade
nicht gerade
hip ist, sondern was sich gerade als
sinnvoll rausgestellt hat.
Zum Beispiel ist ja C-Sharp deutlich funktionaler
geworden jetzt, die letzten zwei Versionen.
Mit Pattern Matching, den ganzen
Lambda Zeug, was dazu gekommen ist.
Kommt sich teilweise schon
wie in irgendeiner funktionalen Sprache vor.
Sebaro kann ein Lied von singen.
Ich hab gehört, der muss Haskell in der Uni
gerade machen.
Äh...
Patrick...
Ich glaub, das krieg ich jetzt nicht aus dem Stegreif hin.
Wir können das aber
mal insgesamt machen. Wir machen einfach
nicht FFM-Pack.
Wir machen einfach mal
Print...
Wir counten eins hoch.
Go, Lip.
Und rufen
aus die Sharp auf. Also ich hab das mal ausprobiert.
Das macht bei wenig
Aufrufen nicht viel aus.
Ich hatte das mal
ausprobiert. Aber bei...
Also wenn's da halt in die Millionen geht, die
aufrufen, macht das was aus. Bei meinem FFM-Pack
Zeug wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weil so ein Frame ist halt...
Selbst wenn's 30 Frames pro Sekunde sind
und das wären 30...
Nee, das ist doch gut.
Wenn die Funktion kürzer ist, macht die Funktion
selbst kaum was und man sieht den eigentlichen Overhead.
Bei meinem FFM-Pack Zeug
ist das eigentlich fast egal. Selbst wenn
ich 30 Frames pro Sekunde hab,
bis ich da mal irgendwo in Bereiche komme,
wo das relevant wäre,
ist...
drauf geschissen.
Aber mir geht's trotzdem auf den Keks.
Ja...
Bett durfte ich übrigens nicht beziehen.
Google Dark Mode!
Haben die da einen Knopf für?
Wo geht das?
Geht das nur, wenn man eingeloggt ist?
Wo machen wir das denn?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wo macht man das?
Ich könnte den Darkreader einfach
anmachen. Eats.
Easy!
Na ja.
Wisst ihr was Leute, mir war langweilig.
Mir ist immer noch langweilig, aber ich gehe jetzt auf
Welche seite nutzt du dich um rund ums programmieren auf dem laufe zu halten reddit ich guck ich habe eigentlich alle
halbwegs großen
programmiert subs
Für windows linux die schar ja war sogar javascript als mögliche
Gesappt bestimmt 60 stück oder so da gucke ich halt immer mal so rein was es für neue sachen gibt
Javascript ignoriere ich die hälfte fall javascript gibt es jeden tag drei neue frameworks die hip sind
Da warte ich immer mal ein bisschen ab was so rauskommt
Hast du jemals eine winera lizenz ervorfen
Der gag ist mittlerweile der gag ist mittlerweile eigentlich outdated
Ob es irgendjemand gibt, den ich follow, den ich raussuchen kann aber keiner da der es nötig hätte
Ja und wir sehen uns morgen früh
Morgen früh bin ich ja wie gewohnt wieder am start
Zum sonntaglichen aufwach streben
Den gibt es ja schon seit zwei jahren jeden sonntag
Ja ich weiß kong hat sich angeblich eine winera lizenz gekauft
Also wir sehen uns bis morgen machts gut
See you
Wollt ihr noch autosong oder geht es ohne mit naja gut
Bis morgen früh co
Und